for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university in the
production of more videos please visit
moof university comm thank you and enjoy
so up until this video we've talked
about the electron configuration
specifically up atoms right and now
we're going to talk about the electron
configurations of ions specifically
monatomic ions which is basically just
when an atom becomes an ion by either
gaining or losing electrons and more
specifically we're going to talk about
the main group monatomic ions which are
the group 1 a 2 a 3 a 4 a 5 a 6 a 7 8 8
a we're not gonna talk about all of them
were gonna talk about the idea that kind
of surrounds them all and here are some
common ions that we see a lot in general
chemistry and we should probably know
what's going on with them right in their
electron configurations it's really
useful to know so a quick note sodium
the alkali metal right that a little bit
neater sodium na readily forms the
sodium plus one ion doesn't form a +2
ion or a minus ion or any other ion of
than na plus y right why is that
chlorine readily forms CL - not
not CL + or CL 2 + or any other ion why
is this at answer this we have to think
about the electron configurations of
those ions and the orbital diagrams so
sodium goes to sodium + and loses an
electron we write that in this reaction
going from na to na plus an electron so
what's the electron configuration that
we start with with sodium
well it's 1s2 2s2 2p6 3s1 3s 1 and the
orbital diagram looks like this
everything is filled up until 3 s 1
which is just half it with one electron
so if it loses an electron that 3s one
goes away and becomes 3 s 0 so we have
1s2 2s2 2p6 and so the orbital diagram
looks like this
all right 3s is empty
what's going on with this this na+ now
is isoelectronic with neon which means
it has the same number of electrons as
neon why isn't the unimportant well neon
is a noble gas and noble gases have
completely filled orbitals which is
super super stable okay so basically it
has a noble gas configuration which is
really stable some people might ask well
okay it can lose one electron to have a
noble gas configuration why can't it
just gain seven electrons and have the
configuration of argon instead well in
that case if it gains seven electrons
yeah it'll have Argon's configuration
but has to gain seven negative charges
which means it would result in a minus
seven ion with more charge which is not
stable more charge is not stable right
so if there's if there if we're trying
to make a decision between less overall
charge and more overall charge less
overall charge is more stable okay now
what's going on here sodium is a metal
and metals all tend to lose electrons
they tend to lose electrons to form
positively charged ions called cations
so cations cation is just the term for a
positively charged ion you can kind of
see that here everything to the left of
this little ladder is a metal and so
they all have positive charges okay so
chlorine on the other hand chlorine has
a configuration everything up until neon
and then 3s2 3p5 which it's orbital
diagram looks like this 3s2 3p5 so it
gains an electron to become CL minus so
that becomes 3s2 3p6 which is
isoelectronic with argon
okay and it's orbital diagram is now
filled with electrons so again the
question is why wouldn't it lose seven
electrons instead well I mean it just
wouldn't be stable to have all that all
that charge right so basically the same
reason as before now nonmetals to the
right of that little ladder on the
periodic table they gain electrons they
gain electrons to form negatively
charged ions called anions okay the
point is here the main group elements
are gaining or losing electrons to
attain a filled outer energy level right
or noble gas configuration and that is
really stable so that's kind of what's
going on there okay another example for
larger main group elements it works a
bit differently for example tin which is
SN on the periodic table
over here it can form SN 2 plus or SN 4
plus so what's going on there so SN s
configuration is 5 s 2 4 D 10 5 P 2 ok
and so let's think about the first
example of giving getting the SN 2 plus
ion
so going from SN to SN 2 plus it loses
two electrons which two electrons does
it lose well it actually loses the ones
that are in the highest energy level so
the highest energy level will be the 5p
so it would become 5 s 2 4 d 10 and then
5 p 0 if you really want to write it in
but it would lose those two out there in
the orbital diagram so it's new
configuration as that ion would look
like that now this isn't quite a noble
gas configuration right so but it's but
it's stable right all these all these
orbitals are completely filled up but
the 5p isn't filled right so it's not a
noble gas configuration so what this is
called is a pseudo noble gas
configuration
which basically you just hinting at the
idea that it's stable but it's not quite
noble gas stable okay but it can also
form a four plus ion so how would that
work well again it's configuration
starts off as 5s to 4d 10 5p 2 so we can
imagine losing those first two 5p right
the next highest would be 5s right and
in fact loses those two okay so its
orbital diagram will look like this just
have all the four D orbitals filled and
thus its configuration will be
everything up till Krypton and then the
4d 10 okay so that's what's going on
there so it's also stable right but not
quite a noble gas stable oh I'd like to
make a note though that lead is right
under 10 and it it forms the same ions
for the four pretty much the same reason
so know that lead is in the same column
and basically has the same situation
going on with it
in fact we mentioned sodium before and
chlorine before so sodium forms that +1
ion and the the rest of the alkali
metals in the group 1 elements will
basically do it the same way and for a
chlorine the other halogens will do
something similar so hopefully you can
imagine what's going on with some of
these other elements and how they form
their ions yeah just on this table now
of course these aren't all the potential
ions that could form there's a like so
many elements can become ions this is
just a rough idea what's going on some
people asked though what about carbon
what's going on with carbon because it's
far away from a noble gas configuration
either way it can either gain 4 1 2 3 4
to become a noble noble gas
configuration or can lose 4 1 2 3 4
carbon doesn't quite gain or lose
electrons not not like not like we've
seen here carbon shares electrons it's
more of us sharing is caring kind of an
element carbon shares electrons when
forming compounds
via covalent bonding and that's
something we'll talk about later but I
hope that video was helpful thank you
for watching if you found that video
helpful don't forget to Like comment
subscribe and share with friends thank
you and happy studying